tout d'abord je tiens à vous dire que je
suis ravi d'être ici avec vous d'autant
plus que cette présence je ne la dois ni
à l'écriture d'essai sociologique
brillant ni à l'invention d'un concept
bénéfique à l'humanité toute
entière ni même à l'exercice d'une
activité professionnelle remarquable non
loin de là puisqu'en vérité je travaille
à la
télévision je fais des reportages pour
Canal plus dans l'émission du midi je
fais aussi un peu le malin dans une
rubrique diffusée chaque vendredi qui
s'appelle vue de l'extérieur qui parle
de la presse étrangère toujours dans la
même émission je ne prétends pas
connaître la télévision par cœur mais je
vais essayer de vous parler correctement
de ce que je connais le mieux
c'est-à-dire les reportages et
l'information à la télé donc vaste sujet
si vaste d'ailleurs qu'au début je ne
savais pas comment exactement le
prendre en fait la question que je me
posais c'est l'homme est-il l'humain
est-il au cœur de la
télévision en d'autres termes la
télévision laisse-t-elle la place à la
bienveillance à l'altruisme à la
générosité mais aussi et c'est important
et complémentaire à mon ble vie à la
complexité de la pensé de la pensée
pardon alors au début je ne savais pas
exactement comment faire et je me suis
dit je vais demander conseil à mon
entourage oui j'ai été faible plutôt que
de plonger en moi pour chercher les
réponses je suis allé chercher des
réponses ailleurs je me suis donc
naturellement tourné vers
quelqu'un de plus jeune qui aurait
potentiellement un regard frais sans
cynisme sans désillusions dé nuué de
tout à priori et je suis donc qui allait
poser la question à ma bellefille pietra
pietra qui a 18
ans donc l qu'est-ce que tu aurais à
dire toi sur la place de l'humain à la
télévision bah il y en a
pas la réponse est intéressante le point
de vue est peut-être un peu
tranché peut-être un poil court quand
même mais
bon
il faut dire que tout de même il en va
tout de même de la de notre
société car oui nous autres en France
nous regardons la télévision 3h45 en
moyenne par jour
3h45 par
jour donc si la télé ne laisse pas de
place à l'humain bien mal barré les amis
et
oui une télé qui se contenterait de de
privilégier l'audience le buzz pourrait
nourrir toutes nos basses pulsions
toutes nos angoisses consumérisme
maladif repli sur soi pessimisme latant
sentiment de malaise peur de l'étranger
non personne ne peut oser imaginer que
la télévision contribuerait aujourd'hui
à ériger une société française qui
ressemblerait à
ça serait trop moche n'est-ce pas
d'ailleurs moi qui travaille depuis
maintenant 20 ans je peux vous le dire
j'ai quand même participé à une ou deux
émissions très
dignes j'ai même
entreaperçu chez quelques directeurs des
programme quelques producteurs peut-être
même en fouinant bien chez un animateur
une faible lueur d'humanité qui m'a
donné confiance en l'avenir de ce média
si si je vous jure enfin bon quand on
parle de télévision comme du reste
Martine est
infidèle extraconjugale qu'elle a entamé
il y a 8 mois dans le plus grand secret
pour retrouver sa sexualité la femme
d'affa garde l'anonymat mais elle nous
entraîne dans son parcours adultère
comme pour briser le
tabou il faut pas tout caricaturer donc
évidemment problème c'est que certaines
émissions sont pires que les pires des
caricatures l'occurrence il s'agit d'un
reportage qui a été diffusé sur une
chaîne très connue à 20h30
20h45 alors c'est un reportage sur les
les couples en difficulté bon je je
d'accord le sujet est un peu futile mais
je l'ai pris comme exemple parce que
déjà je connais la journaliste qui l'a
réalisé ce petit chat d'œuvre et
puis je je pense qu'il illustre aussi
assez bien la façon dont la télé peut se
révéler une hum j'entends par là la
façon dont elle peut utiliser l'homme
comme simple matière à récit bon alors
je passe donc sur la qualité intrinsèque
du documentaire et je vais essayer de
m'attacher à la méthode de
fabrication bon la journaliste a tourné
elle a monté ensuite elle a montré son
sujet au producteur et à la chaîne elle
l'a remonté une vingtaine de fois parce
que tu comprends c'est pas assez
percutant cocote et puis après quelques
concessions elle a livré la version
finale elle était assez fière d'elle
elle a organisé une petite soirée à la
maison pour le soir de la diffusion mais
au moment où le reportage a été diffusé
elle s'est aperçu que ce qui passait
n'avait plus grandchose à voir avec ce
qu'elle avait monté pourquoi B parce
qu'entre temps son reportage avait été
remonté dans son dos dans une version
beaucoup plus sensationnaliste avec de
sur croix force détail des personnels
intimes et croustillant que lui avait
livré les témoins tout en lui demandant
évidemment de ne pas les mentionner dans
le
reportage résultat notre jeune
journaliste a passé la soirée à pleurer
en regardant son sujet à la télé tout en
répondant au téléphone à ces témoins qui
eux-mêmes pleuraient et l'insultaient au
fur à mesure qu'il découvrait à quel
point ils avaient été
trahis bon pas
trèsluisant
mais à mon sens il y a encore plus
grave il est 22h au sud de Grenoble au
pied des tours de la Ville-Neuve un des
quartiers sensibles de l'agglomération
se joue une guerre de territoire entre
jeunes et policiers alors le casre ce
reportage dont on vient d'entendre un
cours extrait est intéressant en tout
cas moi ça me parle beaucoup parce que
c'est à peu près l'inverse de ce que
j'essaie de faire dans l'exercice de mon
métier c'est un reportage qui s'intitule
Villeneuve rêve brisé qui a été diffusé
dans c'est pas n'importe quelle émission
dans Envoyé Spécial sur France 2 le 26
septembre dernier alors on y décrit une
cité à Grenoble atroce extrêmement
anxiogène sans la moindre lueur d'espoir
où règne la délincance le trafic d'armes
et cetera et cetera et bien figurez-vous
que les habitants du
quartier ont attaqué France 2 en
diffamation j'ai l'impression que c'est
une première alors ça m'intriguer j'ai
appelé le représentant de l'association
des habitants du quartier et que
m'a-t-il dit la caricature faite par ce
reportage a été tellement énorme que
nous avons décidé de ne pas accepter et
de nous défendre qu' répondu les
rédactrices en chef d'envoyer spécial
par voix de presse
interposé nous avons l'habitude de ce
genre de réaction face à un miroir tendu
à une réalité qui ne plaît pas
ok ce qui signifie en clair écoutez les
gars vous êtes bien sympa mais nous
depuis notre studio de télé à Paris on
connaît quand même mieux votre quartier
alors que vous qui habitez depuis 10 20
ou 30 ans
intéressant détail non moins intéressant
à l'audience du tribunal de grande
instance de Grenoble l'avocat des
habitants du quartier a sorti la note
d'intention du reportage note
d'intention titrée Villeneuve de
l'utopie à
l'enfer titre rédigé bien sûr avant même
que la journaliste ne se soit rendue sur
place pour faire les premiersres
pages qu'est-ce que ça nous raconte bon
on veut imposer une vision fantasmée du
quartier on cherche à fabriquer et à
vendre un reportage donct on imagine à
priori qu'il suscitera l'intérêt des
téléspectateurs on se moque bien des
gens du quartier de leur réalité de leur
vision et même des conséquences que ça
pourrait avoir sur eux et on se contre
fiche que les téléspectateurs se
construisent une fausse opinion fondée
sur des
contrevérités opinion qui justifie
ensuite parfois la peur et la
haine bon maintenant je tiens à vous
dire que je voudrais pas non plus
m'ériger en perd la morale en donneur de
leçon et je sais bien que là la
frontière est un peu fine d'ailleurs à
mon tour il m'arrive sans doute parfois
aussi de céder à certaines facilités de
caricaturer certains traits de choisir
de mettre en avant un aspect de la
réalité plutôt qu'un
autre mais bon j'essaie de ne jamais
céder à ce sensationnalisme et puis ces
dernières années puisque j'ai la chance
aussi de travailler avec des gens qui ne
sont pas dans cette recherche permanente
j'ai pu développer une nouvelle habitude
un truc de
dingue je me suis attaché à faire des
reportages
positif qui mettent en valeur des gens
et des initiatives remarquables par
exemple anina tu étudiante Rome admise à
la Sorbonne à l'époque où dans les
médiia à la télévision on ne parlait que
du problème Rome Ali cavari boxeur
afghan qui défend aujourd'hui les
couleurs du club de Calais 5 ans après
avoir quitté son pays en
guerre reportage réalisé au moment où la
mère de Calais appelait à la
dénonciation des migrants sur sa propre
page
facebook Maurice barthelémi qui se bat
avec des vieux amis pour que son île
jersey ne soit plus un paradis fiscal
encore des Romes dans un village en
Loire Atlantique un village qui
s'appelle Indre des Romes qui sont
intégrés qui ont tous du travail à
l'époque où manuel Vals déclarait
solennellement que les Romes avaient av
vocation à rentrer dans leur pays encore
une encore une femme Nicole Picard
président d'une association qui rend
meilleure la vie de ses habitants à
aubervillier les habitants d'une cité et
à qui un artiste de street art a rendu
hommage en peignant le plus grand
portrait jamais peint au sol au
monde voilà en quelque sorte ma modeste
réponse humaine télévisée au clichés
visuel bon en même temps il faut pas non
plus que cette façon de faire devienne
un dogme et à ce propos je voudrais
prendre un
exemple concret et relativement
récent concernant la jeune leonarda oui
concernant la jeune leonarda il se
trouve que j'étais pardon il se trouve
que j'étais à mitrovit au Kosovo en
octobre dernier
vous savez quand il y a eu cette folie
médiatique avant pendant et après la
déclaration de François Hollande bon
alors pour ceux qui vivent loin d'ici ou
qui ont été plongés dans un long long
long profond commeat etque à l'automne
dernier je rappelle que leonarda dibrani
est une jeune collégienne qui a été
arrêtée par la police française lors
d'une sortie scolaire en bus puis
expulsé du territoire avec sa famille
alors je vais pas refaire refaire les
relancer les polémiques
les chaînes d'info ont-ils fait trop
est-ce la faute de la bféisation de
l'info fallait-il expulser la famille
fallait-il la faire revenir chacun a eu
le temps de se faire sa propre opinion
sur le sujet en revanche ce dont je
voudrais parler
c'est l'embarras dans lequel ce
reportage m'a mis tout d'abord pour être
tout à fait honnête avec vous je
comprendais rien je vous jure compreneis
rien le matin je discutais avec leonarda
et son pap
etbrani il me disait un truc le midi il
me disait autre chose le soir il y avait
une troisième version qui contrisait les
deux précédentes et puis avec toutes ces
caméras autour d'eux j'ai eu
l'impression qu' qu'il se transformait
peu à peu eux-mêmes en candidat de
d'émission de téléréalité ça je c un peu
le loft au Kosovo
quoi et puis ce qui me gênait
profondément c'est qu'avec mon collègue
caméraman quand on les interviewait on
se disait mais c'est pas possible mais
quand les gens vont entendre ça quand
les téléspectateurs qui vont regarder
notre partage vont entendre ça ils vont
les prendre pour des cééras pour des
fripouilles pour des cruches et ça ça me
gênait profondément
pourquoi parce qu'aux yeux de tous les
d'un nombre enfin certains citoyens
français d'hommes politiques de tout
bord de commentateurs ils étaient
devenus plus qu'une simple famille de
demandeur d'asile expulsé ils étaient
devenenus le symbole des demandeurs
d'asile
expulsé le symbole des Romes et donc je
me disais mais mon reportage va
contribuer à nourrir l'image désastreuse
à collé au Rome en particulier déjà dans
les médiia et à la
télévision alors quoi faire bah pas
grandchose sinon que cela m'a confirmé
quelque chose de très précis de très
important dans ce métier et pas facile
face à la volonté de simplification de
ma rédaction à Paris oui la télé est
aussi l'empire de la simplification je
suis sûr que vous l'aviez déjà remarqué
il allait falloir
essayer à ma modeste mesure de raconter
l'histoire le plus clairement
possible dans sa
complexité ce que j'ai essayé de
faire
voilà j'ai j'ai parlé de du métier de
journaliste de ma responsabilité de
journaliste mais il y a aussi notre
responsabilité de
téléspectateur nous autres tous ensemble
téléspectateurs avons à nous emparer de
cette responsabilité alors comment nous
pouvons faire pour essayer de rendre
cette télévision plus humaine bon
déjà exerçons notre sens critique
sachons reconnaître les reportages et
émissions caricaturales formaté
inhumaine mais aussi et surtout
tirons-en les conclusions qui s'imposent
C son de regarder les émissions les
reportages faits par ceux qui nous
prennent pour des
demeurer et ouais avec un peu de chance
ces émissions seront remplacé par
d'autres moins commercial peut-être plus
honnête et
ainsi
nous réussirons ensemble à restaurer ce
qui est aujourd'hui très entamé la
confiance mutuelle
entre journaliste télé et
téléspectateur la confiance mutuelle
celle qui nous rend plus humain de très
grandes choses ont souvent été réalisé
parce que deux hommes face à face se
sont regardé et enens saisir cette
seconde indéfin qui est la
confiance merci beaucoup pour votre
écoute